اهلا بكم شكرا لليال نتابع في هذه التغطيه
المستمره للزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا منظمه الصحه العالميه اعادت
التاكيد قبل قليل على ان حصيله القتل التي
تخطط خمسه وثلاثين الفا في البلدين مرشحه
للارتفاع مشيره الى انها تنسق مع الاطراف
جميعها لضمان دخول المساعدات الى سوريا
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
اخويا
في مقبره جماعيه بولايه هاتاي تركيا دفنت
السلطات اكثر من خمسه الاف شخص قضوا في
الزلزال المدمر الزميل عمار الهندي تفقد
المقبره واعد لنا هذا التقرير
نحن في مقبره هاتايا الجديده التي استحدثت
لدفن ضحايا الزلزال المدمر هذه هي الصور
من مقبره هاتاي الجديده هذه الارقام على
القبور
للموتى توضع بعد ان يتم تصوير الضحايا
ووضع ارقام واعطائهم ارقام معينه ومن بعد
ذلك يتم دفنها تاتي الجثث الى تلك الزاويه
تصور الجثث وبعد ذلك يتم دفنها بارقام
حتى يتسنى لمن لم يعرف مصير اقاربه ان
ياتي ويسال
معنا من هاطاي جنوب تركيا مفرد العربيه
عمار هندي يبقى معنا اذن مع ارتفاع عدد
القتلى الى خمسه وثلاثين الفا في كل من
سوريا وتركيا اذا عمار رغم اقترابنا من
اكمال اسبوع على الزلزال الا انه المشهد
قد لا يبدو عليه وكانه مر اسبوع بسبب عظم
الكارثه وهول الماساه كيف هو المشهد الان
طاهر اولا نحن فعلا نقترب من نهايه اليوم
السابع اسبوع على هذه الكارثه واسبوع على
مدينه مدمره كانطاكيا وهاتاي عموما اعتقد
طاهر يعني ان الحديث في الايام المقبله
سيكون عن الجثث ورائحه الجثث ورائحه الموت
المنتشره في كل مكان في هذه المدينه يعني
انا اتحدث اليك واشتم رائحه الجثث للاسف
يعني في هذا الحي الان لم يعد هنالك اي
امل في الوجود او العثور على ناجين سوى
شخص واحد تم انقاذه صباح هذا اليوم من جثه
من من مبنى هنا كان تحت الانقاض لمده
تقريبا 6 ايام ونصف وخرج سالما وللاسف ان
هنالك العديد من العائلات كهذه التي تشعل
النيران هنا
للتدفئه لا تزال تنتظر يعني خروج المفق من
تحت الانقاض وهذه العائله ليست وحدها
هنالك عائلات كثيره لا تزال تنتظر
والعمليات مستمره والكاميرا سترصد لك كل
شيء ولكن انا اتبادر الي يعني الى ذهني
سؤال وانا اشتم رائحه الجثث والموت ما
خطوره هذا الامر خصوصا ان المباني والدمار
لا يزال هائل ولا يزال كثير والوقت يعني
بدا ينفذ من الجميع في العثور على ناجين
والان بات البحث يعني او العمليات تتركز
على امكانيه في اسرع وقت العثور على
الجثامين والجثث التي تتواجد تحت الانقاض
كنت اتساءل كم سيستغرق هذا الامر من وقت
يعني اذا كنا في اليوم السابع ونشتم هذه
الروائح
وماذا سيحدث يعني هذه عائله ايضا تنتظر
لحظه العثور هذه عائلات كثيره هنا وانت
تشاهدها طاهر
تنتظر هذه العمليات وفرق الانقاذ وفرق
الرافعات ترفع الانقاض للعثور على من لا
يزال تحت الانقاض هنالك عائلات باكملها
طبعا ليس في هذا المبنى وحسب وانما في
مباني كثيره وانا ساتوجه معك
لاستعرض اكثر على يمينك هناك ايضا عائلات
تجلس وعلى يسار الشاشه هنالك عائلات تجلس
تنتظر هؤلاء لهم سبعه ايام ينتظرون العثور
على ذويهم انا للاسف طاهر فقدت الاتصال لا
اسمعك لا ادري ان كنت تتحدث اليه ولكن
ساصبح
الكلمه كل الكلمه للميدان في هذه الساعات
يعني ان احببت ان
تشاهدها
نحن معك عمار ونتابع واياك هذه الصور لا
ادري ان كنت تسمعني الان الكلمه كانت
وحدها لك في هذه الايام العصيبه التي
تعيشها تركيا وسوريا لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت
الميدان وما يحصل للناس من ماثم وكوارث لا
داعي مع الصور وكلام المراسلين على الارض
وضيوف الذين نتواصل معهم ان يضيف احد شيئا
على هول ما عاشه الناس وما يزالون يعيشونه
وما سيعيشونه لسنوات ممن نجوا خاصه من
الذين فقدوا احبائهم او اصيبوا عمار اذا
يبدو انه فقدنا الاتصال بعمار الهندي ولكن
الصوره لا تزال تصلنا من عنده من هاتاي
التركيه من جنوب تركيا هاتاي يعني من
الاكثر تضررا من هذا الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا وسوريا نحن قد نعود الى عمار الهندي
لاحقا في سياق تغطياتنا شكرا جزيلا لك
للان على الاقل ونتابع ما لدينا في هذه
التغطيه مش
ارتفاع عدد قتل زلزال سوريا وتركيا الى
نحو 35 الفا فيما كان هناك توقعات امميه
بان هذا العدد قد يرتفع اكثر فاكثر
طيب لا ادري اذا كان عمار عاد الينا الان
عمار تسمعني
عمار الهندي اذا عمار اهلا بك مجددا كنت
اريد ان اسالك
عن لسان حال الناس عن مطالباتهم للسلطات
عامه يقولونه عن الاداء منذ البدايه حتى
الان وما الذي لا يزالون يتوقعونه معا
انهيار الامال اكثر فاكثر بامكانيه انقاذ
عالقين
طاهر انا ساتحدث اليك بصراحه وبوضوح هنالك
عدد من الشكاوى يعني انا التقيت اناس
وعائلات كثيره تشتكي من عده امور هنالك من
يشتكي بان لديه جثامين يريد نقلها ولا
يستجيب له احد هنالك من يشتكي بان هنالك
بنايات لم تصلها حتى هذه اللحظه عمليات
الانقاذ والبحث عن جثامين تحت الانقاض
وعناجين وهنالك من يشتكي بانه لا يعرف كيف
الطريقه للوصول او للاستفسار عن شخص مفقود
من خلال منصه موحده حتى هذه اللحظه وكما
تعلم الان البعض انا
طلب منا ان نصمت
لانه عندما يبدو هم يعني يستمعون الى صوت
خلال عمليات
هذا جيد يعني ان شاء الله ان تكون لحظات
تبشر بخير رغم مرور كل هذا الوقت انا يعني
ساتابع عنك مع هذه الصوره المتوفره لدينا
من قبلك ومن عند الزملاء
وارجو ان تعطيني اشاره اذا كان بالامكان
لاحقا ان تعيد التواصل معنا بالكلام واذا
كان بالامكان ان نبقي الاضاءه تحت الا اذا
منعوكم من ذلك ارجوا اخبارنا كذلك اذا
مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه قال انه سيزور
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا المتضرره من الزلزال
وكان بانتظار موافقه الجهات المسيطره على
شمال غرب سوريا لدخول المساعدات وقالت
الصحه العالميه انها اطلقت اليوم نداء
لجمع ثلاثه واربعين مليون دولار لدعم
متضررين الزلزال مع توزيع 110 اطنان من
الامدادات الطبيه في سوريا حتى الان تحدثت
منظمه الصحه العالميه عن ان الاوضاع في
شمال غرب سوريا وحلب هي الاصعب وقالت نسعى
لايجاد وسيله لتقديم المساعدات لهذه
المناطق عبر الحدود وتخشى من انتشار
الاوبئه نتيجه للتداعيات الزلزال على
المناطق المنكوبه كان المرصد السوري تحدث
عن ارتفاع عدد او حصيله قتل الزلزال في
سوريا الى 5000 و300 الصحه العالميه ايضا
كانت تحدثت عن التنسيق مع كافه الاطراف
لدخول المساعدات الانسانيه لسوريا وان
اعداد ضحايا الزلزال مرشحه للزياده في
سوريا وتركيا بانتظار التقديرات الاجماليه
لعدد ضحايا الزلزال اذا كان عمار الهندي
مفرد العربيه الى هاتاي جنوب تركيا يتحدث
الينا ثم طلب منهم من فرق الاسعاف
والانقاذ يعني ان
يصمت وذلك يكون احيانا لسماع اصوات تحت
الانقاض ومن ثم قد نتبين لاحقا ما كانت
حقيقه الامر على الاقل لدينا صوره من هناك
حتى الان الامال يعني وان خبت قليلا الا
انها لا تنتهي يبقى هناك امل ويبقى هناك
معجزات تحدث احيانا ولو مع اقترابنا من
اتمام اسبوع كامل على هذا الزلزال المدمر
هناك بعض الاشخاص الذين يجدونهم احياء في
الساعات الاخيره نحن سنواصل في تغطيتنا في
هذه الساعه والساعه مستمره من العربيه
لتغطيه هذا الزلزال وقد نعود الى هذه
الصوره والى عمار الهندي لاحقا
[موسيقى]
ما بشتغل لانه الباب كمان
لانه هو الباب كابس
خليك صاحي يا عمي خليك صاحي يلا يلا حبيبي
يلا الله يقويك ما شاء الله عليك ان شاء
الله عليك
العمل
[موسيقى]
هذا ورصدت كاميرا العربيه توقف نحو 100
شاحنه محمله بالوقود والمواد الاغاثيه
ارسلت من مناطق الاداره الكرديه ولا تزال
عالقه في معبر ام جلود الفاصل بين مناطق
سيطره قسد ومناطق الفصائل المواليه
للتركيا التي ترفض مرور هذه الشاحنات الى
ادلب وريف حلب
انا الان في معبر ام الجلود
الفاصل بين مناطق الاكراد حيث اقف وبين
مناطق المعارضه كما تظهر في الصوره هذا هو
الجدار الذي يفصل او بوابه المعبر التي
تفصل بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه ومناطق
المعارضه في شمال غرب البلاد لا يزال
الوضع على حاله دون اي تغيير لم تدخل واي
واحده من
الشاحنات التي
ارسلتها الاداره الذاتيه وعددها هنا في
المعبر كما تلاحظ 30 شاحنه محمله
بالوقود اي مادتين البنزين والمازوت
المطلوبه بشكل سريع في المناطق المتضرريه
ليشحها هناك ايضا هناك سبع شاحنات محمله
بالمواد الاغاثيه موجوده مقدمه من الاهالي
ولم تدخل حتى الان
يتوقع ايضا ان تصل خلال يعني ساعات 42
شاحنه محمله بالمواد الطبيه واليغاثيه
مقدمه من منظمات المجتمع المدني والاهالي
الى هذه المنطقه نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 100
شاحنه هنا في معبر ام جلود من المفترض ان
تدخل الى مناطق المعارضه ليس ببعيد من هنا
نحن يعني على بعد حوالي عشر دقائق من معبر
التائهه وهو معبر ايضا تتواجد فيه 100
شاحنه اخرى اضافه الى شاحنات وسيارات
اسعاف ارسلتها الاداره الذاتيه ويفترض ان
تصل الى مناطق النظام في حلب
من ريف حلب الصحفي احمد ابو لؤي اهلا بك
استاذ احمد ما حقيقه الامر بخصوص تعثر
ادخال هذه المساعدات ما الذي نعرفه
تحياتي عزيزي يعني
تعسر الدخول المشاهدات كانت من اليوم
الاول ان لاحظنا يعني لبعد ثلاثه ايام
دخلت اول شاحنه طبعا وكانت فيها
مؤدرجه يعني لما قبل الزلزال ومن وفي
اليوم التالي دخل 12 حافله من مناطق
العراق مقدما مؤسسه البرزاني اضافه الى
يعني 14 شاحنه معبر باب الهواء طبعا اليوم
السبب الرئيسي يعني باعتقادي هو الجانب
التركي بالتعاون مع فصائل المعارضه يعني
لا يعني هو الاحتمال الوحيد لعدم دخول
المشاهدات الى هذه المناطق يعني اليوم بعد
سته ايام على الزلزال اليوم نحن في اليوم
الوحيد
العامل الوحيد او الاحتمال الوحيد عفوا
احتمال الوحيد هو
الجانب التركي بالاتفاق مع فصائل
بسبب علاقة تركيا بالقوات الكرديه نعم نعم
نعم بالضبط يعني بعد ما سته ايام على
كارثه الزلزال التي الذي ضرب شمال غربي
البلاد يعني
الدفاع المدني انتهاء عملياتهم بالبحث
وانقاذ العالقين
والبدء بعمليات الانتشار طبعا لم ياخذوا
القرار فرق الدفاع المدني الا بعد فقدان
الامل بالادخال الاجهزه الذكيه الاليات
الاجهزه الذكيه طبعا للبحث عن العالقين
ولو وافتهم المنيه اضافه الى الاليات
والادوات والجرافات وغيرها يعني حتى اليوم
لم يتم الاستجابه للدفاع المدني يعني هذه
كارثه كبيره اليوم اذا نظرنا الى ايضا
ارتفاع اعداد الضحايا الى
2168 حاله وفاه طبعا الحيز الاكبر كان من
نصيبه جنديرس المنكوبه حيث وصل عدد
الضحايا الى 513 تلاها مدينه ساعود اليك
معلش استاذ احمد نحن نذهب الى عمار الهندي
يبدو لديه جديد نحن نشاهد صوره من عنده في
الجانب منها على الاقل ان نراها كامل عمار
الكلمه لك
نعم نعم طاهر يبدو انا معجزه جديده يعني
تحدث للتو الان وصلوا الى شخص على قيد
الحياه وهم في حاله من الصدمه لانهم لم
يتوقعوا ذلك طلبوا يعني معدات طبيه طلبوا
اطباء وطلبوا اشخاص يقوموا بازاله الحطام
حتى يتسنى لهم اخراجه طبعا كانوا طلبوا
منا الصمت قبل قليل ونحن معك على الهواء
فتبين فعلا انه على قيد الحياه في هذه
النقطه التي يعملون فيها
هنالك يعني صراخ كثير وارباك لانهم لم
يكونوا يعني لم يكونوا يتوقعوا فعلا ان
يخرج شخص
مع تقريبا نهايه اليوم السابع فيه وخصوصا
ان ساعات المساء طاهر بارده جدا وهو اكبر
تحدي قد يواجه الشخص الذي يتواجد تحت
الانقاض نحن سنبقي عينا على هذه الصوره
معك طاهر لحين اخراجه
عامل الانقاذ الذي توصل اليه كان يعني في
حاله صدمه يطلب يعني يصرخ ويطلب من مساعده
في ان ياتي عمال الانقاذ الى جانبه لازاله
الركام الذي يحيط بالجثه بالشخص عفوا الذي
لا يزال على قيد الحياه ويطلب مساعده طلب
من احد الاطباء ان يقترب ومعه سماعه
واقترب فعلا وذهب الى تلك النقطه لا يسمح
انت كما تشاهد الشرطه اغلقت المكان يعني
لا يسمح لاحد ان يقترب الان ربما
لا خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه
خلي الاضاءه خلي الاضاءه خليه الاضاءه
خلي الاضاءه اتركها نحن
طاهر معك سنبقى عينا على هذه الصوره ما
حدث بانهم عثروا على شخص لا يزال على قيد
الحياه وطلبوا بحاله يعني حاله من الارباك
والصدمه المساعده لاخراجه
هم الان على ما يبدو يعني انا رايت طبيبه
دخلت
وعلى ما يبدو انها امراه
الحيه التي تتواجد تحت انقاض هذا المبنى
الامر يعني لم يكن متوقعا بالنسبه لهم
لانه عمليات البحث عن ناجين طوال هذا
اليوم كانت مستمره
وكانوا فحصوا اكثر من نقطه واكدوا انه لا
وجود للحياه لاي شخص ولكن للتو معجزه
جديده فعلا ان خرجت هذه السيده حيه ستكون
معجزه جديده وبالتالي ربما تعيد حساباتهم
فيما يتعلق بهذا المبنى وهذا هذه المنطقه
السكنيه باكملها والبحث من جديد عن اشخاص
ناجين
طبعا اداره الكوارث التركيه كانت اعلنت
اليوم ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزال الى 29 الف
وستمائه وخمسه وتحدثت عن اجلاء نحو 148
الف شخص من المناطق المنكوبه لولايات اخرى
وعن تسجيل
منذ زلزال الاسبوع الماضي تركيا اضافت
4600 حاله وفاه الى حصيله قتلى الزلزال
خلال الساعات الماضيه مع اذن مرور الساعات
واقترابنا من اتمام اسبوع كامل على هذا
الزلزال مع توقف بعض
المساعدات نحو 100 شاحنه تقريبا توقفت عند
معبر ام جلود شمال سوريا للاسف الوضع
ربما يعني يصح ان نقول انه اكثر ماساويه
الماساه ماساه على الجميع ولكن مع شح
الامكانيات عدم وصول المساعدات بسرعه الى
بعض المناطق السوريه اصبحت الماساه مضاعفه
اذن هذا هو الواقع مع مرور نحو اسبوع اقل
اسبوع بساعات قليله على ما حدث والحكومه
التركيه اعلنت طبعا مرارا كانت بدات بوقف
متعهدين بنايات ولكن اليوم اعلنت ايضا
مجددا عن تحقيق موسع مع مقاولي البناء
بسبب انهيار الاف البنايات جراء الزلزال
كان ايضا كنا نقلنا الكثير عن ما وصلت
اليه الحمله الشعبيه ساهم في السعوديه
لجمع الاموال وصلت حوالي 80 مليون دولار
اضافه الى انقاذ فريق انقاذ السعودي
عندما رصد صوت طفل تحت الانقاض في غازي
عنتاب كان اتحدث مراسل العربيه عن ان فريق
لانقاذ السعودي رصد صوت طفل تحت الانقاط
في غازي عنتاب مع تاكيد العدل التركيه فتح
تحقيق اذا مع مقاولي المباني الجديده
المهاره بسبب الزلزال واعتقال 62 من منهم
من مقاولي البناء في اطار التحقيقات
وانشاء مكاتب تحقيق في جرائم الزلازل
والوفيات
والاصابات ايضا هذه بعض اخر الاخبار التي
وصلت منذ الساعات الماضيه في متابعه
لاخر اخبار الزلزال والتداعيات الجسيمه
وعلى كافه الاصعده بالمناسبه ليس فقط
الحاله الانسانيه والماساويه انما كل
التداعيات الامنيه والسياسيه
لما حدث في تركيا وسوريا وعلاقه ذلك
بالوضع السياسي ودول الجوار والعالم نحن
لازلنا نشاهد هذه الصوره من عند عمار
الهندي من هاتاي مفرد العربيه الى هاتاي
التركيه من الاكثر تضررا عمار اي جديد
ماذا نعرف
نعم نعم
جلبوا سياره اسعاف تقف هنا ربما تمهيدا
لاخراجه من تحت الانقاض ونقله الى سياره
الاسعاف هي تقف من خلفي ويعني طبعا يعني
بات هنالك جمع كبير من رجال الاسعاف
والانقاذ جاؤوا الى هذه النقطه وادخلوا
ايضا ضوء الى الداخل ربما لاخراجه بطريقه
سهله سليمه
ودون ان اخراجها السيده وهي سيده على ما
اعتقد حسب ما بلغني اخراجها بطريقه سليمه
دون ان تصاب باذى عندما تتم هذه الاجراءات
كلها وتصبح فرق الاسعاف والانقاذ طلب
الصمت
اذا ولكن تبقى معنا بالصوره على الاقل
ونعود اليك بعد قليل اذا بانتظار يعني ان
تخرج هذه السيده حيه ان شاء الله نامل ان
يكون الوقت قصيرا بين الاعلان عن ذلك عن
يعني عن استدعاء فرق الاسعاف وانتشاله
نامل ان يكون الوقت قصيرا وبالتالي يعني
نشاهد بعد قليل اخراج هذه السيده بعد نحو
اسبوع على هذا الزلزال هذه ستكون ايضا
يعني معجزه جديده كما تسمى في هذا الزلزال
يعني عاده من المفترض انه عندما تستدعى
الفرق وتصبح على هبه الاستعداد وبكل هذه
الجهوزيه لابد وان تكون اقتربت من يعني
تحقيق ذلك ومن انتشال احد على قيد الحياه
رغم الحاله
الجسديه طبعا التي يكون عليها من هو تحت
الانقاض طول هذه المده اذا نحن بانتظار
انتشال فرق البحث والانقاذ
انتشال شخص ما على قيد الحياه
يعني سمع صوته او صوتها تحت الانقاض
بهالطاي هي بعد مرور سبعه ايام على
الزلزال وبانتظار ان يحدث ذلك لابد وان
ننتظر وكم يعني هي ساعات الانتظار
عندنا بسيطه امام ساعات وايام الانتظار
التي عاشها من هو تحت الانقاض وهو يعني
على قيد الحياه ولكن ليس هناك من ينتشره
وستكون معجزه اذا تم ذلك بعد سبعه ايام
طبعا هناك الكثير من الاخبار من الجانبين
السوري والتركي بالتزامن مع مرور اسبوع
على هذه
[موسيقى]
الكارثه على هذه الماساه
ولكن الاخبار لا تتوقف وكانها اليوم الاول
او الثاني لهول ما حصل حتى على صعيد النهب
والسرقه وهذا ينتشر في هذه الحالات
نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي قليلا اذا كان عمار
لا يزال يعني بغير امكانه انه يتحدث
احتراما لما طلب منه حيث هو من فرق
الاسعاف والانقاذ كي يعني تسود لحظات من
الصمت يستطيع من خلالها رجال الانقاذ ان
يسعفوا ان يستمعوا الى صوت او انين من هو
تحت الانقاض نامل ان يكون
العدد اكثر من شخص ويتم التمكن من انقاذهم
وهم على قيد الحياه يعني لازلنا نشاهد هذه
الصوره
لرجال الاسعاف والانقاذ وهم يتجمعون فوق
انقاض احد المباني في هاتاي حيث اعمال
الانقاذ مستمره في بعض المناطق استكملت
هذه الاعمال في مناطق اخرى لا تزال قائمه
وفي
سوريا للاسف
الحاله اص واقصى مع الوضع المعروف هناك
على صعيد يعني عدم وجود كل الامكانيات
اللازمه وعدم ادخال المساعدات منذ اللحظات
الاولى الى المناطق المنكوبه طبعا الحكومه
التركيه كانت تحدثت عن ثمانيه الاف مبنى
في عشر مدن متضرره من الزلزال تحتاج الى
ازاله عاجله اما الصليب الاحمر فكان قال
انه مساحه المنطقه المتضرره من الزلزال
بتركيا وسوريا تعادل دوله بحجم فرنسا اذا
الكلام للصليب الاحمر الذي قال انه مساحه
المنطقه المتضرره من الزلزال بتركيا
وسوريا تعادل دوله بحجم فرنسا اذا كانت
تركيا اعلنت عن انقاذ امراه مسنه اليوم
تبلغ 85 عاما بعد 152 ساعه من بقائها تحت
الانقاض هذه هي الحالات المعجزات التي
نتحدث عنها اضافه الى عدد من الاطفال
الذين نذكر انه تم انقاذهم من تحت الانقاض
ايضا السلطات التركيه كانت اوقفت 130 من
مقاولي البناء جراء الزلزال مع تاثر 26
مليون شخص بالزلزال في كل من سوريا
وتركيا اذا فرق الانقاذ لا تزال تواصل
بحثها بل وتنجح احيانا في اخراج احد
الناجين من تحت الانقاض في عدد من المناطق
كما حصل في انطاكيا اليوم ايضا وكما نترقب
ونامل ان يحصل في هاتاي حيث عمار الهندي
لا يزال يزودنا مع الفريق العامل معه من
الزملاء بالصوره من
عندهم حيث تتجهز فرق الانقاذ
او تحاول فرق الانقاذ انتشال احد
الناجين يعني علنا نصر على هذه الكلمه
لاحقا او نؤكد عليها وان تكون بالفعل
ناجيه تحت الانقاض اذا بانتظار ان يسمح
لعمار الهندي بان يستكمل رسالته وان نعرف
ما الذي يعني يقال له في هذه الاثناء
سنعود اليه بعد قليل
ونذكر بان مئات العائلات مئات العائلات في
جنديرس السوريه كانت ابلغت عن مفقودين
وفقا
لمراسلينا على الارض فيما حجم الدمار
يعني يتكشف فصولا في كلا البلدين
نتابع واياكم في رصد هذه الصوره اذا كان
بالامكان ان نبقي عليها واذا كان استاذ
احمد ابو لؤي لا يزال معنا من الصحفي من
ريف حلب ربما نتحدث اليه طيب فقدنا
الاتصال معه اذا نبقي الصوره على يعني
التركيه بانتظار ان تريد ان المزيد من
المعلومات ويمكن ان نذكر
بان
يعني شاحنات المساعدات
مثلا المساعدات السعوديه كانت بدات
بالدخول الى المناطق المنكوبه بشمال غرب
سوريا كما كنا نتابع منذ ايام وقد ضربت
هزه ارضيه بقوه اربع درجات فاصل واحد
ولايه ملاطيا التركيه مع الحديث عن يعني
نحو 2500 هزه ارضيه ضربت ارتداديه ضربت
البلاد ما بعد الزلزال ونحن نراقب الصوره
من عند عمار نتحدث الان الى عمار السلامو
المتطوع بالدفاع المدني السوري من الحدود
السوريه التركيه اهلا بك معنا استاذ عمار
الواقع الان مع اقتراب دخولنا او اتمامنا
اسبوع على الزلزال كيف يبدو من المناطق
التي استطعت ان تعينها او تشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ فيها
عمليات استخراج الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ
الجاريه
وهناك ايضا تواصل مع الجهات المحليه هناك
تمسح حتى الامنيه التي يعني تم انت
هاء منه لجمع المعلومات عن المفقودين من
اجل اكمال واتمام عمليات استخراج الضحايا
من تحت الانفاق لكن
اتركز جهود الدفاع مدني تتركز على التعافي
يعني الكارثه الثانيه هي الكارثه على
الناجون بحاجه
لواء بحاجه الى التحتيه مدمره بالكامل
الجرحى بحاجه الى ادويه بحاجه بحاجه الى
علاج بحاجه الى مشافي يعني استيعابهم
نتعامل كدفاع مدني اليوم مع فتح الطرقات
لاعاده الحياه
وجهود التعافي هي التي نركز عليها خلال
فتره قادمه ايضا هناك جهود لانشاء فرص من
اجل معينه الابنيه المتصدعه هناك مدنيون
نحاول تحضيرهم من عدم الرجوع الى ابو
العوده الى منازلهم لان منازلهم متصدعه
وقد تسقط في اي لحظه يعني هناك مدنيون
يعيشون حتى الان في تلك منازل الدفاع
المدني ايضا يحاول ان يعمل في هذه يعني في
هذا القطاع ويحاول ان يقوم بمسح لتلك
المباني وتحذير صاحبها
امكانيه ازالتها ويعني تدميرها في حال
انها يعني للسقوط او بشكل تمام حكيت عن
مشاركتكم في فتح الطرقات ايضا يعني وكذلك
يعني اجلاء او نقل من كانوا من يعني كانوا
يعيشون في بنايات تصدعت اذا نحن نتحدث عن
مرحله ما بعد الزلزال وفقدان الامل نهائيا
تقريبا يعني من امكانيات حدوث معجزات مع
شحا الامكانات رغم الجهود الجباره التي
قام بها الدفاع المدني في سوريا اضافه الى
كل من كان معنيا بذلك عندما تتحدث عن فتح
الطرقات اولا اي المناطق الاكثر تضررا على
هذا الصعيد وهل لديكم القدرات الكافيه
لفعل ذلك حاليا من حيث المعدات والاليات
والاعداد
جزء من عمل الدفاع المدني وفرقه هو
التعافي تقديم الخدمات لكل قطاعات
الموجوده هنا لان لا يوجد مؤسسات دوله
فنقوم نحن باخذ المسؤوليه يعني
اداره هذا هذه المساله الان هناك فتح
طرقات في جنديرس في مناطق ريف ادلب الغربي
في كل المناطق المتاحه اذا كانت هناك
طرقات وصول المدنيين
للمشافي للمخابز نقوم بفتح تلك الطرقات
وتسهيل يعني حياه الناس
بخصوص البنايات المتصدعه التي تحدثت عنها
وعن اعداد الناس الذين لا يستطيعون العوده
الى بناياتهم عن اي يعني هل هناك امكانيه
هل كان هناك امكانيه في الايام الماضيه
لحصر اعداد هذه البنايات حجم البنايات
التي تحتاج الى ازاله كامله اضافه الى
اعداد هؤلاء الناس الذين كانوا يقطنونها
واذا كان بالامكان ان يتم نقلهم الى اماكن
اخرى والا يعني يفترشون الخيام
هناك ما يقا
رب عفوا معلش تعيد الرقم
اكثر من الف مبنى مدمر بشكل كامل هناك
اكثر من
الفهم لان منازلهم متصدعه او خطره اداعش
الف عائله دمرت منازلهم بشكل كامل
بشكل كامل 11 الف عائله يعني نحن عم نحكي
عن كل عائله مثلا تتالف من عدد من الافراد
يعني العدد هذا بدنا نضربه باربعه او
بخمسه صحيح
ممن دمرت بيوتهم بشكل كامل اضافه الى 30
الف عائله من اصحاب البيوت التي تصدعت
ايضا نضرب الرقم باربعه او خمسه على اقل
تقدير يعني او كمعدل عام وبالتالي ان
نتحدث عن عشرات بل ربما يعني ما يفوق يعني
العشرات مئات الالاف من المتضررين على هذا
الصعيد طيب بالامكانيات يعني لجهه امكانيه
نقلهم الى اين يعني حتى الخيام هل هي
متوفره
بدايه اريد ان اذكر ان الاعداد في تركيا
كمباني
معلش لو سمحت استاذ عمار تبقى معنا لدينا
جديد من عمار الهندي فيها عمار
نعم طاهر على ما يبدو انا كنت تحدثت الى
احد رجال الانقاذ واخبرني بانه لن يسمح
لنا حاليا بالذهاب الى تلك النقطه
لتصويرها عن قرب ولكن اخبرني بانه بمجرد
ان تخرج هذه السيده
سيسمح لنا بتصوير تلك اللحظات ولكن علمت
ايضا منه بان فريقا
وانا بان فريقا بان فريقا المانيا سياتي
للتو ليساعد في اخراجها من حيث هي موجوده
طريق دعم انقاذ الماني سياتي احيانا كثيره
طاهر تاخذ هذه العمليه وقت يعني يكونوا
متاكدين مثلا والشخص امامهم ولكن يعترضهم
على سبيل المثال تعترضهم قطع كبيره
اسمنتيه تحتاج الى تفتيت وبالتالي تبدا
العمليه الجراحيه بحيث تفتت هذه القطع دون
التاثير على صحه وحياه الشخص الصحيح يعني
يصارع من اجل الخروج حي انا كنت سمعت وانت
تتحدث ان هذه اللحظات مرعبه ولكنها ليس
يعني مرعبه ومقلقه بالنسبه لنا ولمن يشاهد
ويترقب اخراج شخص بعد سبعه ايام من تحت
الانقاض ولكنها لا شيء صحيح في مقابل ما
شعر به هذا الشخص تحت الانقاض لايام ورب
كان يصرخ ويستنجد وكان من الصعب ان يسمعه
احد وفي نهايه يعني في نهايه بعد اسبوع
تحت الانقاض يستدل اليه رجال الانقاذ
وبالتالي هذا بالنسبه له سيكون شعور يعني
انا اعجز عن تخيله ولكن هذا المشهد بربما
يعني الان وفي هذا في هذه اللحظات ربما
يعني يكون ثمين جدا لانه الوقت داهم
الجميع اسبوع سبعه ايام وبالتالي حينما
ينبثق هذا الامل الجديد من بين الانقاض
نكون امام حاله فريده صراحه انا لا اعلم
تحديدا كنت تحدثت انت عن الوقت كم تستغرق
وقتا لاخراجها لا اعلم سالته قال لي لا
اعلم ولكنه متاكدون انها حيه ومتواجده
والعمليه عمليه فقط ازاله الحواجز التي
تعيق اخراجها وبالتالي طلبوا فريقا فريق
دعم الماني سياتي للتو ويساعد في اخراجها
نتمنى طبعا ان يتم اخراجها على قيد الحياه
وبحاله ان شاء الله
ان تعود الى الحياه
والانقاب يعني هذا اثر شديد الصعوبه يعني
كانت احتماليه ان يخرج الانسان منه حيا
كبيره جدا
بكل المقاييس وعلى يعني ايضا الوضع لا
يحتمل بالنسبه الى فرق الانقاذ يعني كيف
يعملون وانت تراقبهم وتعيش هذه اللحظات
القاسيه معهم كيف يعملون حدثنا اكثر عن
طرقهم عن الياتهم عن معداتهم عن نفسياتهم
عن الطريقه التي يعملون يتناوبون فيها كيف
يرتاحون مع استمرار عمليات الانقاذ كل هذه
الايام الطويله
انا رايت
انا رايت بعضهم ينام الى جانب
الاماكن التي يعمل فيها فريق يرتاح قليلا
وفريق يعمل هم يعملون على مدار الساعه
هنالك فرق
اجنبيه من بلدان مختلفه تساعد في هذه
العمليات هذه طائره من دون طيار ايضا الان
طاهر فوق هذا المبنى تقوم ببث صور ربما او
تسجيل هذه اللحظات لانقاذ هذه السيده او
هذا الشخص انا اعلم انها سيده من خلال احد
الاشخاص ولكن نعم عملهم مضني ومتعب جدا
وحينما تكون هذه الحاله مثلا يتاكد من
وجود شخص على قيد الحياه تتوقف الاليات
الثقيله وتبدا كما قلت لك عمليه اشبه
بالجراحيه الكبرى يعني تكون حساسه جدا
يستخدم ادوات بسيطه ادوات بدائيه يعملون
فيها يفتتون الحديث يقصون الحديد يفتتون
الاسمنت او يزيلون كل الركام
الخالق وهذا يستغرق احيانا وقت كثير ومضني
ومتعب وهنالك طبعا لحظات ياس شاهدناها
لرجال انقاذ يعني حاولوا لساعات اخراج
ناجل من تحت الانقاض ولم يتمكنوا يعني
بسبب انه فارق الحياه لان العائق كان كبير
اكبر من اي شيء كان يعيق تقدمهم وكانت
التقدم يكون بطيء جدا منها ياخذ ست ساعات
وبالتالي للاسف تكون المسافه طويله يعني
احيانا طاهر ما اريد ان اقوله المسافه
تفصل تفصل شخص تكون المسافه التي تفصل
الشخص عن العوده للحياه سنتيمترات او متر
واحد فقط ولكنه معقد للغايه ان تكون هذا
المتر المسافه
الاف الكيلومترات للوصول اليه طلبوا منا
الصمت
لك ذلك
وللموقف ولرجال الانقاذ على الارض ونتابع
بالصوره على الاقل بانتظار
بحدوث شيء ما على امل ان يكون ذلك قريبا
نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اقطاي يتحدث عن
عدم فقدان الامل في استخراج احياء من تحت
الانقاض اذن ونحن نشاهد في جانب من الصوره
المباشره التي تاتينا منها عند عمار
الهندي هناك مؤتمر صحفي
لنائب الرئيس التركي يتحدث ويقول لم نفقد
الامل في استخراج احياء من تحت الانقاض
ولعله ابرز دليل على ذلك ما
يبلغنا به عمار وينقله الينا من هاتاي حيث
سمعت قبل قليل فرق الانقاذ انينا لسيده
على ما يعتقد لا تزال تحت الانقاض انا
وهرعت هذه الفرق الى مكانها لكي تنقذها
ولكن لا احد يعرف كم من الوقت يمكن ان
ياخذ ذلك لانه قد يكون هناك قطع اسمنتيه
صلبه جدا يعني عصيه على
ان تستخرج السيده من تحتها
وبانتظار ان يحدث ذلك لا احد يعرف نائب
الرئيس التركي حتى يقول انه لم يفقدوا
الامل وعمليات الانقاذ مستمره ولكن
الماساه تبقى كبيره بدون شك رغم كل
المحاوله يعني رغم كل محاولات رجال
الانقاذ ان كان على جانب السوري او الجانب
التركي ورغم كل المساعدات التي وصلت رغم
صحيها تلك التي وصلت الى سوريا بانتظار
المزيد مما يقوله نائب الرئيس التركي نذكر
بما قاله مفوض للاغاثه الاماميه عن الحاجه
الى فتح المزيد من نقاط العبور في الشمال
الغربي السوري مع يعني بدء محاولات
الدفاع المدني
السوري في تلك المناطق اعاده الامور الى
نصابها ما يسمى بمرحله التعافي اذا كما
اخبرنا عمار السلام قبل قليل المتطوع
بالدفاع المدني مرحله فتح الطرقات مرحله
يعني اجلاء الناس او ايواء الناس في
اولئك الذين عمار يبدو لديه جديد عمار
عمار
معك عمار نعم طاهر
لا قلت لك قبل ثوان من الان كانوا صفقوا
جميعا لانها يعني على ما يبدو الشخص الذي
تحت الالقاب تحدث الى المنقذين وسمعوا صوت
بوضوح ولذلك صفق الجميع يعني صفق من هم
هناك رجال الانقاذ وكل من يتجمع هناك
ويعني كان خبر سعيد للغايه لانه على ما
يبدو سمعه صوته بشكل واضح حال هذه العمليه
الانقاذ هذه تسير كما قلت لك نعم هم
تاكدوا بان الشخص على قيد الحياه واننا ما
يحدث الان هو
عمليه اخراجه من تحت الانقاض انا ساحاول
ان اقترب واترك الكاميرا هنا ولكن ساصعد
الى الاعلى حتى اتاكد ربما لكن ارجوك اذا
كان الصوت بدا يتقطع حتى بسبب الارسال الى
الكاميرا ان تخبرني لانه احيانا يتقطع معك
بخلوك تفوت لجوع عم بيخلوك تدخل كل هذه
المسافه الى الداخل
انا ساحاول ان ادخل حقيقه لانه احتاج فقط
ان اعرف المشهد
احتاج فقط انا اعرف المشهد كيف يبدو وما
الذي يحدث تحديدا طاهر يعني هم يغلقون
المكان
عددهم كبير رجال الالقاد هدى طبعا هنالك
ايضا عناصر من الجيش تقف الى جانبي تشرف
على هذه العمليه الان
يعني هنالك فرحه كبيره لديهم يبدو انها
يبدو ان العمليه على ما اعتقد يبدو انها
اسهل مما ظنناه انه قد تتم قريبا ان شاء
الله
احاول انا استكشف يعني يبدو يبدو ذلك يبدو
ان شاء الله يبدو ذلك لانه لانه من خلال
من خلال ما شاهدناه يعني مشاهداتنا
والتجارب التي عشناها لو لم تكن العمليه
قريبه ما بيكونوا بهذه الفرحه
هكذا صراحه نعم نعم لا صحيح صحيح هذا صحيح
تمام وانت تتحدث نائب الرئيس التركي يتحدث
عن 34 الف عنصر انقاذ يعملون في المناطق
المنكوبه بحثا عن احياء ومنهم حيث انت
عمار
العناصر الانقاذ الذين يحاولون انقاذ هذه
السيده
اذا بعد ان قال بانه لم تفقد السلطات
الامل في استخراج احياء من تحت الانقاض
اذا نحن لا زلنا نشاهد صوره عمار الهندي
والزملاء من هاتاي التركيه حيث تتم محاوله
انقاذ احدى الناجيات ان شاء الله ان تم
ذلك بعد قليل نامل ذلك على الاقل اذا يتم
انقاذها من تحت الانقاض بعد سماع صوتها
وبعد يبدو انه يعني استطاعوا ان يتحدثوا
معها قبل قليل ذلك رغم يعني اقتراب تمام
سبعه ايام كامله على هذا الزلزال المدمر
اذا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام في
تغطيتنا المستمره من العربيه لهذا الواقع
الماساوي الذي تعيشه كل من تركيا وسوريا
المزيد من رجال الاسعاف اذا ياتون الان
بكشافاتهم باضواءهم باخوذهم بمساعدات التي
يحملونها
كل ما يقوته من يعني قدرات من اجل انتشال
الاحياء من تحت الانقاض ويصعدون يعني الى
اعلى هذه الانقاض حيث الاليات التي تحاول
يعني
مسح المكان
وازاله كل العقبات
الاسمنتيه كل الركام من اجل انقاذ من يمكن
انقاذه من تحت الانقاض املا بان يحصل ذلك
قريبا جدا بعد ان اخبرنا عمار قبل قليل
بانه يعني حجم فرحه رجال الانقاذ وبانه
تصفيقهم قبل قليل قد يدلان على انه
الموضوع ليس معقدا كما هو في حالات سابقه
ونحن نامل ذلك نتابع رؤيه هذه الصوره
الليليه سوره الركام سوره الماساه التي
تصورها عدسه العربيه فيها تايل التركيه
وكما صورتها في عديد المناطق التركيه
الاخرى والسوريه كذلك رغم الظروف التي
تعيشها تلك المناطق في سوريا
وللاسف رغم شح الامكانات وتعثر حتى ادخال
المساعدات حتى المتوفره منها
لاسباب سياسيه احيانا في مناطق في الشمال
الغربي السوري بانتظار يعني ان يعني
نتخلص من كل هذه الاسباب قريبا جدا من اجل
ايصال المساعدات الاساسيه لمحتاجيها نتابع
في رصد ما يحدث على الجانبين التركي
والسوري وبين لحظه صمت ولحظه فرح ولحظه
تصفيق نامل ان تستمر في هذه البقعه على
الاقل يعني انقاذ ولو شخص ولو روح واحده
من تحت الانقاض بعد الايام السبعه رغم كل
من قتلوا وتوفاهم الله او اصيبوا في هذا
الزلزال المدمر المزيد من المعدات التي
ياتي بها رجال الانقاذ والاسعاف اذا من
حول المكان من اجل اخراج هذه السيده ونحن
كنا نتابع عمليات الانقاذ هناك حين ابلغنا
عمار بانه هناك صوت لسيده سمع من تحت
الانقاض وهرع رجال الانقاذ من اجل
انتشالها من تحت الركام املين ان يتم ذلك
باسرع وقت على الاقل ما نعرفه حتى الان
انه فرق الانقاذ تاكدت من وجود هذا الناجي
او هذه السيده اذا كان ذلك مؤكدا يمكن ان
نعرف لاحقا ان شاء الله تحت انقاذ هذا
المبنى في هاتاي اذا نائب الرئيس التركي
كان تحدث قبل قليل والكثير من المؤتمرات
الصحفيه اليوم لسلطات التركيه ايضا هناك
الان في هذه الساعات النظر
في امكانيه فتح مزيد من المعابر الحدوديه
لايصال المساعده الى شمال غرب سوريا وفقا
لما ينقله مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
السلطات السوريه اذا يعني بانتظار ان
تتكشف المزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه النقطه
نذكر بالحاجه الى فتح مزيد من المعابر
بسرعه كما قال المفاوض الاغاثه عمار
نعم طاهر العمليه تجري هم يزيلون الركام
من حيث يوجد هذا الناجي على قيد الحياه
تحت الانقاض انا طبعا لم ارى الصوره بشكل
واضح بمعنى لم ارى تفاصيل
ما يعيق عمل رجال الانقاذ لانه في عددهم
كبير ويتجمعون حول المكان ولكن على ما
يبدو ان لديهم الان ما يستخدمونه لقص
الحديد
نعم نعم لا هم اعادوا اعادوا الجهاز الذي
يستخدم لقص الحديد لذلك اعتقد ان العمليه
اقرب مما نتخيل او مما حدث في حالات عديده
كعدوه بمعنى انهم لا يحتاجونه
اكثر من ذلك على ايه بمعنى انهم لم
يحتاجوه نعم نعم نعم بمعنى انهم لا نعم
نعم ولذلك اعتقد انها
لن ان شاء الله نامل ذلك
الان السلطات يعني المتواجده او المؤسسات
المختلفه المتواجده كل هؤلاء الرجال الذين
نراهم يهرعون الى المكان يعني اذا استطعت
في خلال هذه الساعات انه تحددهم تحدثت لنا
عن وجود عناصر جيش عن عناصر اسعاف دفاع
مدني من يعني ابرز المؤسسات بها طاهر
صحيح صحيح خلال ثلاث ايام الاخيره انتشرت
عناصر الجيش التركي في كل مكان في لا هم
يقومون بتمديد هذا الجهاز الذي يستخدم لقص
الحديد على ما يبدو لاستخدامه
يقومون باستخدامه
يقومون بمد الاسلاك
الى الداخل ولكن كنت اتحدث اليك عن الجيش
التركي نعم الجيش التركي الان يتوزع على
كل الاماكن كل البنايات المدمره وكل مكان
فيه رفع للانقاذ وخصوصا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طلبوا منا الصمت مره اخرى
اذا
لحظات صمت يجب ان تسود في تلك المنطقه لكي
يتمكن رجال الانقاذ من اتمام مهمتهم يعني
الصوره تبقى من عندك عمار نراها بوضوح
لرجال الانقاذ وهم يحاولون يعني استكمال
خططهم واساليبهم لاتمام هذه العمليه
لانتشال هذه الناجيه المفترضه تحت الارض
يعني هم سمعوا صوتها واستطاعوا ان يتحدثوا
اليها على ما يبدو صفقوا فرحوا ولكن
بانتظار ان يتمكنوا من ازاله كل الركام
فوقها لكي يقوموا بانتشالها نحن بانتظار
ذلك على كل التغطيه مستمره ان لم يتم ذلك
في خلال هذه الساعه فان شاء الله ان يتم
في بدايه الساعه المقبله
مع زميله ميسون مؤيد ونحن نذكر
باخر الاخبار التي وصلتنا اذا كانت
التركيز في هذه الساعه محاوله انقاذ ناجن
او ناجيه تحت انقاض هذا المبنى المنهار في
هاتاي ولكن الحديث الان بدا ينصب اكثر على
مرحله ما بعد الزلزال فتح الطرقات معالجه
ترميم البنايات التي يمكن ترميمها من
البنايات المتصدعه ايواء الناس ايصال
المساعدات فتح المزيد من المعابر بالنسبه
الى سوريا بالنسبه الى تركيا اعتقال عدد
كبير من المتعهدين من المتعهدين مقاولات
لاستجوابهم لاتهامات قد توجه اليهم
في ديار بكر يبدو لدينا انتشار لاحد
النجين اذا فرق الانقاذ يبدو انها تنتشر
احد الناجين من ديار بكر
ونرى ذلك في جانب من الصوره اذن
ونتابعها بوضوح لفرق الانقاذ وكل المؤسسات
التركيه المنوط بها هذا العمل الانساني في
ديار بكر في ديار بكر اذا جانب من الصوره
والصوره الاخرى
اذا صوره يمين الشاشه في ديار بكر وهناك
محاوله لاخراج
الناجي ان شاء الله ان يكون ذلك قريبا جدا
وان يكون بصحه جيده ناجي او ناجيه والصوره
الاخرى في يسار الشاشه هناك يعني محاوله
كما كان يخبرنا عمار الهندي لانقاذ احدى
الناجيات ان شاء الله اذا فرق الانقاذ في
ديار بكر تخرج احد الناجين من تحت الانقاض
في يمين الشاشه الصور لمحاولات انقاذ اخرى
فيها التركيه اذا بانتظار ان يتم ذلك
باقرب وقت نتابع في تغطياتنا من العربيه
بالتزامن مع اقترابنا من اتمام الاسبوع
الكامل على هذه الفاجعه على هذه الماساه
التي حلت بتركيا نتابع اذا مع ميسون بعد
قليل في هذه التغطيه
والقاكم العشيره بتوقيت السعوديه ان شاء
الله لمتابعه هذه التغطيه التي استمرت
معكم طيله الايام السبعه على شاشه العربيه
تركيا اذا لدينا صورتان صوره صوره فرق
الانقاذ في ديار بكر وصوره فرق الانقاذ في
هاتاي ومحاولتان لانقاذ ناجيين يعني من
هذين المكانين على امل ان يتم ذلك قريبا
جدا وان تستمر هذه المعجزات يعني
الظهور في تركيا وفي سوريا كذلك لاستخراج
من تحت الانقاذ رغم هول الماساه ورغم
العدد الفادح المهول للقتله الذين فقدناهم
في هذه الكارثه